no bail for two suspects tied to a
deadly crime spree on new year's eve
josani carter and jordan ruby accused of
killing two people at the fashion show
and paula station parking garages hector
mejia was in court with them
both suspects will remain with no bail
while investigators try to figure out if
those suspects are connected to other
crimes around the valley 18 year old
jordan ruby and 20 year old jaisani
carter each face three felony charges
open murder one attempted robbery and
one conspiracy to commit robbery on new
year's eve police say these two shot and
killed 66 year old clarice yamaguchi
outside of her car in the fashion show
mall parking garage while trying to rob
her later in the evening police say the
pair went to the palace station parking
garage where they killed a second person
who has not yet been identified by the
coroner's office also prosecutors did
not say when they plan to file a second
murder charge both suspects are expected
back in the courtroom here in downtown
on monday reporting in downtown hector
mejia live local now